les gens aiment croire aux contes de fées
prêts bien sûr et vous, je crois que
les personnages que nous lisons sur la page
finissent par être plus réels que les hommes que vous
tenez à nos côtés,
je suis st.  Jack Jack et laissez-moi le
chèque laissez-moi vérifier les gens ni l'
histoire dont
ils ont besoin pour savoir que de vrais hommes
vivaient réellement ici
Je me suis habitué à un grand fossé
entre ce que les gens croient en ce que je
sais être et comment voudriez-vous
qu'il se souvienne  il devrait y avoir plus de chevaux
plus de soldats faites-vous ce mr.
Kennedy pleure plus quelles caméras
c'est ma finition ressemble à notre caserne
bougeons avec vous vous n'avez pas à le
faire je marcherai avec Jack seul si le
jour du nid n'est plus j'ai perdu jack quelque part ce qui
était réel bien que ses pyramides
je te devine  ne me permettra pas d'écrire
quoi que ce soit non parce que je n'ai jamais dit ça